we have seen Aid coming from the UK in
the by the government but we've also
seen firefighters heading this way as
well let's bring in Matt rack should we
um he's the head of the fire brigade
Union I wonder if we could start with
that please first Matt many of your
members heading this way to do what they
can
good morning okay yes we have uh
specialists in the vine rescue service
at fire brigade junior members and they
many of them have traveled all over the
world to disasters such as earthquakes
included in this occasion and I want to
pay tribute to them obviously uh it's a
remarkable work they're doing in most
appalling circumstances
yeah I wonder if I could also ask you uh
about the fact that I think you've
postponed uh the next strike following
an increased payoff for uh during
lengthy talks with the employers what
can you tell me yeah so we were at a
meeting with the employers late into the
night last night and we have a revised
payoffer uh we haven't called any
strikes so we haven't postponed anything
but we simply regret we've decided that
we will not call any strikes while we
consult our members it is an improved
payoffer it's still below inflation but
it's a two-year offer of seven percent
and five percent uh that is a change and
that we have agreed that we will put
that to our members and they will make a
decision on that over the next few weeks
so we will ballot them and they will
have to assess what that means to them
uh weighing that up against going on
strike and so on and they will make that
decision now
that's backdated to July of last year so
yeah the the year one seven percent will
be back dated to July the first last
year and then five percent uh offer from
July the first this year and I suppose
the the advantage of of where we are is
that we have negotiated in some of the
other public sector disputes there are
pay-review bodies who effectively it
seems to me impose pay offers on uh
workforces without negotiations uh the
difference with us is we don't have a
pay-review buddy and frankly we don't
want one we actually negotiate with our
employers and that allows some movement
so in this case they have moved from two
percent to five percent now to seven and
five percent that's clearly a shift in
position and that's what our members
will consider
um equally it's still below inflation
and you know our members will weigh up
all the different factors that that they
face in in their lives in their working
lives and with their families
yeah 88 of firefighters and control room
staff I'm told voted in favor of strike
action I'm guessing that they want
um an inflation busting pay rise are you
gonna hold out for that
look we haven't uh assessed we've only
got this uh offer late last night we
acknowledge it is a significant Movement
by our employers but as you say it's not
inflation busting certainly for year one
we don't know the position for year two
the 2023 position
um but it is clearly movement from our
employers and we welcome that and that's
the useful how useful dialogue uh can be
and our members will assess all those
things because clearly going on strike
is a big step to take as well people
suffer financial and other hardships by
going on strike but our members will
make that decision they've been involved
all the way through they told us they
didn't want two percent they told us uh
overwhelmingly they didn't want five
percent we will now put this offer to
them we're a democratic organization and
our our members ordinary firefighters
across the UK will make that decision
do you see your members as essential
workers
absolutely they they perform a a
life-saving public safety role every day
of their working lives and you can see
that's in in Stark example you've given
from the earthquakes uh now but here in
the UK every day keeping people safe in
making sure buildings are safe uh
inspecting buildings and of course
responded to 999 calls but fires other
emergencies uh absolutely an essential
Workforce considered key workers during
the pandemic
thank you
but given that the reason I ask you that
Matt is given that you're an essential
service the government is going to stop
you striking
uh well yeah absolutely disgraceful
attacking of UK on on our rights and we
will continue to campaign against that
law uh and it is uh really undemocratic
particularly in the middle of a campaign
in the middle of discussions about
paying campaigns on pay to change the
rules indeed to change the law is uh
frankly undemocratic and the NRV
authoritarian uh examples have been
drawn where our comparisons have been
drawn with the situation in Europe we
familiar with the position of
firefighters in Europe and the position
is completely different to here
firefighters have much stronger
employment rights and protections and
Trade union rights in the countries that
have been quoted by government ministers
so this proposed law is completely
undemocratic and we will fight it every
step of the way
okay it's good to talk to you do let us
know what happens as far as going back
to your members are concerned what
happens next thanks for your time this
morning thank you